I'm deep in the cave whoa what is that
oh I'm outside okay never mind touch
that's the sky that's what they call the
sky oh I thought that was like the roof
of this fluffy things shut up geez what
you have to go so far because I'm a
caller right I'm a shot-caller here yeah
do you yeah okay this is copper ore but
we need aluminum you tell you might as
well get this stuff haha I fell I fell
I'm not dead thankfully okay I'm fine
I'm fine I know you were worried about
me but I'm fine now
[ __ ] I Jack I kind of came again stop
doing that
okay I'm not quite brave enough to go
jumping down there just yet who what are
you what the hell are you I don't know
what this is but it's big bulbous and
goofy I don't want to get near it
you touch it no suck it I'd rather not
[Laughter]
that's the point of the game you taught
me yeah okay but you got to be
conservative about your sucking you
can't Oh found it found aluminum or god
I gotta got it cool cool cool cool I
might die down here but you know you
vented basically gonna die but just come
closer and I'll pick up your body okay
all right then I have a five spots full
of uh copper well okay more could you oh
god there's something ah the demons
begin coming out of me
all right hand I got I might be able to
get one or waited ACK
nothing's too far to sac so you're
actually right because that's already I
believe okay I've got three stacks of
aluminum or I'm gonna try to make my way
back because if I die that's gonna be
heartbreaking or whatever you'd be so
sad you'd miss me right you missed me oh
yeah where my fearless leader this
where can i suck in not suck you won't
let me suck something yeah some things
but then other things it will it's so
difficult to know what to suck such as
the mysteries of the way of the suck I
need to need to be stronger of mine not
an domestic I don't know too much about
the second wave you've never read suck
zoos suck of all her succeed you never
read that no I can't say I have can you
lend it to me haha I'll give you an
esteemed copy from the very from the
Congressional library it's a rare first
edition slightly moist around the edges
the pages are kind of got a little bit
yeah but it's it's really it's really a
delightful delightful read you should
you should pick it up sometime you I
think it will
wait so you pack it are you back at the
base yes I most certainly oh my god when
did you get back at the base I thought
we had an invader in our system like
someone like someone in Dark Souls just
came in to [ __ ] up our day dad no you
can't do that man I was going to say
let's go screw somebody oh yeah let's go
screw somebody hey I've learned how to
[ __ ] yeah and blow yeah I want to learn
how to screw see look this was all
euphemism you're taking it in too
literal terms and that's not okay it's
not okay man not okay not okay go I'd
say I'm an expert at this game by now
I'd say you're an a-hole that too but
you know mostly the expert thing
yeah whatever how about mostly not yeah
you're an expert not got him um excuse
me use me I'm an expert would I
oh whoa what the hell happened why didnt
hey wait come on
why is this this vehicle day not
allowing me to build it what the heck is
happening here you should like wailing
I've no I can't put this second piece of
aluminum here it's right there we go I
got okay blowing big little little
dingdong dingdong [ __ ] there we have it
we have a vehicle bay you excited about
that mmm-hmm we can drive we got a storm
income and we got a storm income big
papa we gotta get my charm coming away I
don't think that our way so I think we
might be in the clear but I'm not on
presenta sure never minds coming
straight for us big Papi's get by bear
get in your chair I'm gonna kill my
goddamn pod you're not in the chair on
my screen oh there you are I am in the
chair I'm not in the chair
lovely then see where I am nope yes I
can of course I can I'm not sitting in
the chair there for Big Papi you're in
the chair on my screen storm passes
right by in there but oh I haven't
served the episode hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
Astra near I'm here with Wolfie hey so
we just got the vehicle vehicle Bay
underway but what we need is we need
more compound to be able to build the
rover do you have any compound or big
poppa pump I died that doesn't answer my
question
never mind big Baba bump I got it all
underway so let me try to build us up a
rover clue but they do be excuse me and
then like I immediately Oh God get out
of my rover alright so I got a problem
there's only one seat on this bad boy
here well it's easy y'all drive whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm gonna build
another one seater so that we both can
be on that do we have any more compound
uh probably I'm putting the beacon on
the thing if Ike where's the compound
yeah don't put the beacon on it I've got
it
no I've gained I know you didn't I have
to put another chair on that because
that is my vehicle and I could not
figure it out i opposite and figured out
a a rocks like running after he rocks
running after me yeah that rocks flying
at you pretty angrily I know
happens it happens I'm going to build
since if we got some more of aluminum
I'm going to build a wind turbine
because if you notice we can only
generate power in the day or when
there's direct sunlight but if I build a
wind generator we're going to be able to
build get power whenever there's wind
make sounds cool I'm gonna do that you
can't copy it's happening no matter what
you say it's going to happen it's
already done I take your things too late
it's already done
we got a wind turbine Big Poppa Pump
nevermind when to stop we got to power
it immediately that was not a very
effective Big Poppa go on it red gutters
dynamite
I could go blow on it yeah alright this
is where your ultimate test of blow
comes in Wolfie blow god that's the
wrong button blow like the wind
hey what button is blow trying
everything worked out it only goes to 5
I give up now you failed me you failed
me for the last time I have like really
long legs in a very wide crotch hell
yeah ok congratulations man
congratulations oh thank you I'd like to
think it was older genetics but man you
proved me wrong
alright I'm gonna go try to find more
guy know what that was what sitting down
on a chair really hard spreading legs
all day long I had to put in the work
putting in the work is sitting in that
chair really hard heck yeah I do not
think the program how my parents doubted
me for years about whether or not it was
a good idea to sit hard in that chair
and look at me I said I showed them I
showed him how man could sit in a chair
real hard and then look how they look at
me now with my shirt on my crotch space
yeah I showed my parents my crotch space
they were amazed they were something
they were something alright and I quote
they said excuse me to spit it
yep excuse me son
do you think this is an effective use
the joke is not funny isn't it something
it's something it's that's something all
right your dog needs it's something it
just needs to be something yeah yeah so
long as it makes one person laugh I
guess that's good enough yeah and since
there's two people here only one person
at a time can tell a joke I guess the
margarine Ferrer is pretty low yeah all
right fine then I'll get hearing it out
I have more compound and I'm gonna be
back but I just I'm so close to
finishing out this stack but I think
we're completely bone dry on compound
here yeah I've been looking for compound
too because I need tethers I think
that's resin no don't waste it on tether
no tethers our compound there's our
compound yes they are they are indeed we
broke the system we didn't break the
custom hood wait what do you have what
is this organic it doesn't listen it's
so stick with me okay don't think with
me we all knew that you knew that I knew
that we all knew that Eddy sure all
right I'm on the way back we need more
huh uh-oh I'm talking to myself yeah you
should be
we need more what nothing I'm gonna keep
my secrets to myself in the evening
whatever you're doing over there for Oh
compounds - I'm taking where are you
uh-oh you're on the other side okay yes
that way I've got a backpack full of
compound and I'm carrying another
compound in my hands just because I'm
that manly I don't have enough energy to
keep doing this for a while oh god oh my
cell get get to the tether then it gives
you energy
yeah it does fill me all right get me
yeah compound oh how did that scream
help you get go
I'm getting aa because I found a baby
ah ah God found 5l force I sucked it dry
you sure did
sure did did it proud good you did good
they suck this side dry you got to try
every side you know maybe not but I did
manage I did manage to get this other
thing so that we can have two seats on
this bad boy right there
and then blam hell yeah Oh energy though
wait what the hell what the hell did I
just do here
did you just say to me [ __ ] did you just
say to me you think you can that uh we
were USA why is this not charging wait
what what I've compound what why is it
not charging this should be charging
it's not charging why is it I are not in
any seat it's there we go it's not it's
not what it's not powering why is it not
charging I don't know I don't know
vehicles it should be charging all right
hang on um I did it what you did I
connected it whoa how'd you do that I
just click the button what your genius
okay
hop in oh you it hop in there no oh my
teacher doctor wait mother oh not yet
for other sisters uncle they were all
wrong all right hop in are you ready I'm
ready
almost burski all right here we go oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
turn over I don't think it's gonna turn
over Rover Rover turn on over Oh No oh
haha that didn't work and I in the
ground I'm dead I'm gonna die no no no
you're fine do you see where I am
getting again hit tab there you go there
you got it
all right we can't we press on into the
distance for my memory for
Oh swooning women ah here we go
plunder yes alright try to find the
goodies deep within
try not to dig under it you goof stick
inside it I found a broken piece good
job yeah that was what the wrong kind of
be something any right Oh found it found
the goodies hey yeah I came in the other
side
I'm sure there's hopper weed and you're
late we can we double teamed it didn't
we okay I'm blind hang on hey no I can't
fit this grab this I forgot I have too
much compact it go get it okay I go back
in and get it I'm stuck get it there we
go go back in and get it don't you leave
me how could I leave you I'm literally
not going anywhere
you'll go insane without me you think
you think you can't take it now yeah I
can uh yeah you're right I can't take it
now but I have a funny feeling that
you're a factor in that all right we
don't have a lot of battery left so
let's keep going let's just go in the
opposite direction it'll it'll get more
power later uh I don't know if it will
hey they don't see you got power there
we could say mm I'll get out and push I
don't think we can push [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
well I'm not getting out last time I did
I got stuck in all right you stay right
there man didn't you say they lowered
the center of gravity Wow okay yeah
might need to get out of that get out oh
god oh god
there we go well God what are you doing
okay there we are swimming in the ground
there we all right we don't have that
much power I don't know if we're gonna
make it
that's right you know nope don't you
dare I thought it was like a 2-way Drive
I could su up we are about to run out of
power I have a solar panel I'll put it
on ye I come on this thing this is
supported beyond the words get out
I ain't won't let me I keep pressing cab
get out there we go
she's alright we only have a scooch more
power just believe
power not we're going to drift the rest
of okay yeah coast come on come on right
there there oh oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright I gotta go back enter I don't
have a tether on me me nope that's not
working we can just build a new one we
need to research more stuff you run out
of gas get a new car right that makes
sense to me I don't know what else would
say Hannah let me yeah I've got a batter
whatever me I might pull it in
baby baby baby
there we go got it alright let me take
that over there okay
alright let me put those see Kevin
wasn't that fun and useful for us to go
to this that was real good something we
got so much something we got so much
some I came to describe the kinds of
something that we got I took something
whoops I got lithium whatever that does
I got rhythm Lance iam I got scorpion
other things it's um uh um I got like a
Lana dumb I got Lana Del Rio
I got Nickelback boom I got lots of good
stuff alright so we don't need organic
don't know what we need to do is we need
to get we need to have a better way of
getting more researchable x' so the only
problem here is that we don't have a
cave right next to us but we can always
dig down until we hit a cave you know
what I mean
yes no speech ball to speech ball just
dig right here start digging down in a
nice slope so that we can get out
hopefully and just keep digging down
that seems like a plan it's a lie wait
I'll wait to see what else but it's a
plan and a plan yeah
I'm gonna build more tether hang on
there you keep digging I'll build more
tether cuz I got oodles of company it's
right into more farty gas I'm out of
power
hang on I'm building more tethering on
just don't stop complaining come two
seconds stop complaining for two goddamn
oh my light have power if I do
oh it turned off nevermind at weight oh
there we go alright you're good
ah yeah I thought the power in that one
alright one more just keep digging
straight at a nice land eventually we'll
hit a cave and then when we're in that
cave we can do lots of good
what's it taking so long for me to get
power back I'm connected to the tether
because probably the generators aren't
giving all that much power because you
know there's either no Sun or nor no
wind you know what I mean
yes I'm stuck there we go this fun I
always like digging in games I just like
it's very calming to just dig away at
the ground until nothing yeah it's a and
some of it too it's like in Minecraft
it's very OCD yeah it is yeah which is
kind of nice yeah just make all the bah
we found it we found it we got it we
nailed it okay whew so if you dig out
with your digger right if you dig out
plants and stuff ah they they have
researchable x' at the bottom of them so
I'm going to take this one back i'ma go
research it out like for plants and I
didn't see anything well then you're not
clicking hard enough do me I got more
mallet dead mallow Dada now let the DA
okay alright sure that's what it's
called
doesn't matter it does matter what
matters is friendship there's a storm of
heritage yeah you're right that jokes
not funny
what matters is we're not funny how am I
getting winded in here I don't know
there's a storm but I'm out of the way
well our wind generator is just having a
field day with this power though so if
that's nice I probably shouldn't leave
the cave but I'm gonna don't leave the
cave it's current we're currently right
in the middle of it and it's real deadly
out here I got plenty of copper good
gonna be warm at night it's to rub the
copper on your Italy yeah ah that's the
good stuff question
mark it feels so good yeah warm me
copper
fix me copper all right pologize for
that got caught up in the moment this
storm is last in a long time but I don't
see any flying debris so I'm gonna risk
your getting wrong I don't know man
who knows the mysteries of the blow yeah
I guess that's always been a human kind
biggest question mmm where does the blow
come from all right I'm coming back down
if you find any more researchable
no but I got a bunch of copper I've been
looking for a compound because I wanted
to tether but there was aluminum over
here you didn't get the aluminum you
stupid goof nope I'm going into the dark
what it is nothing what is that a wall
it's dead people ah no that's where they
put up that's where they put grandma
okay I'm going to take three something
yeah dig up those Quigley's Bay at the
bottom of them usually have researchable
might take this [ __ ] back with me I'm
not getting research but I'm getting
plenty of hydrazine well geez that's not
what we need is it huh is it it's fuel
good feel for what we don't have a
generator for our imagination good gosh
darn goof we don't have imagination all
right with that oh yeah I was gonna
don't worry I wasn't planning on
commenting I'm just I'm annoyed that
this plant didn't give me anything so
I'm just gonna keep digging under it
right okay Oh somewhere yeah okay
all right that's good there's other
plants there's a researchable right here
you goof wait it's literally right there
I got it
don't worry I got it do you orderly was
right there oh I died how did it I dug
up a planet exploded on me what did you
do that
why are you standing directly on the
things you're digging
um make sure I dig right uh where are
you
I didn't going nowhere to go I'm going
to your research
the hole is literally adjacent to our
base how could you miss it
hmm oh and you come from I came out of
the hole it's adjacent to perfect oh the
other one
Oh trade platform that is really really
nice so that's useful because the trade
platform allows us to be able to
transfer materials by sending it off
world and then blabbity blah blah
happens and blah blah blah so let me see
if I can build a subform well I don't
have any resin ash yet yeah I don't
either
okay well anyway that's good enough for
this episode oh there's resin right over
here let me see if I can build that I
don't think it's about where I got to
when I was playing by myself so good job
you've been holding me back this whole
time yeah I'm pretty sure that shut up
I'm pretty sure [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure your ass I didn't know I
had so much on my pack
I was really packing haha okay you don't
need me Reed's telling jokes on your own
what do you need me for there were those
words that a god amazing
one of them was I'm coming that wall I
slid congratulations did you die why
don't we build stairs cuz we can't not
many ways that might be bad astronaut
like flailing as he jumps up the wide
crotch Oh cute and chubby
yeah and it's why so huge well I don't
want to be the leg yet it amputated but
he's lucky his his dick was really big
and now it works out cuz it looks like
you got too late that's not about rude
though yeah I believe that that sounds
right yeah I'm gonna build a train flat
my god we need doo doo dee dee
diddly-dee see the trade platform is
actually a vehicle so what you want okay
what do we want what do we want
what I
I want I have a copper and fuel so we
don't need that so what do we need we
need researchable x' which is what you
were supposed to be doing you're
supposed to be going getting
researchable i exploded up flower Oh
excuses okay so we'll we'll figure this
out next time because we're all full up
also this is where you can because if
you if you put this here then you'll see
what you'll yield when you trade it make
sense if you put a compound here it'll
yield nothing cuz it's worthless all
right wait gonna that's all the time we
got for this one here thank you
everybody so much for watching we're
making good progress thank you Wolfie
for joining me any last words um it's
really fun yeah it's pretty fun I am
pretty sure I mastered it yeah you're
pretty good at it I'd say pretty good so
anyway that's all the time we got check
out wolfies channel through the link in
the description below thank you again
everybody so much for watching let us
know we're doing down comments and as
always we will see you in the next video
[Music]